- I've reacted to a bunch
of Try Guys' medical videos.
And now, they're about to see
who's gonna live the longest.
Peewoop!
- I don't know how long I'm gonna live.
- That's normal.
- I think I'm a little afraid to know.
- My biggest hurdle, is that I love food.
And, flavors come from fat, and salt,
and sugar, and all these things
that are bad for you.
And, I would be unpleasantly
surprised to find out
that some of my life habits
before, are unfixable.
- Our lifestyle habits
most definitely contribute
to the longevity of our lives.
But, something that is
less often considered,
the quality of our lives.
What if I was to tell you,
one of your habits will
only shorten your life
by maybe, five years.
You were gonna live to 100, now 95.
But, the 30 years before
that, you're gonna have
to be on oxygen, you won't
be able to breathe well,
you won't be able
to run around with your
kids and grandchildren.
That's an important factor, isn't it?
- Couple weeks ago, we
sent in this color kit
with a sample of our saliva,
to find out about our genetic disposition
and any sort of health
issues we might be needing
to watch out for.
- We analyze, 60 different genes,
30 cancer, 30 heart health genes.
It really just gives you
kind of a more tailored look
at your cancer and your heart health.
- I'm gonna say it outright, so
that you understand where
my biases lie, going
into this video.
I think these types of
tests are largely useless.
Not saying genetic tests
are largely useless,
'cause there's absolutely a role for it.
We actually have geneticists
that work in hospitals that
help with genetic planning.
If you have a genetic condition
that you wanna make sure
that if you're having children,
it won't be passed down
or if it will be, what are
the percentages, et cetera?
But, the ones that are
commercially available
to tell you how long you'll live,
not only are they terribly inaccurate
'cause they can't possibly
take in all the variants
that can go on in one's life,
they also don't test for everything.
And, at times, can give you
a false sense of security
that ultimately ends up
worsening your behaviors.
- So, I took the color test.
So, you know everything about me now.
- So, we (chuckles).
- Do I have chlamydia?
- Color does not test for that.
- Oh, that was a different test, okay.
- So, we analyzed 30
different genes related
to things like hereditary
high cholesterol,
and different heart diseases,
and we didn't find any mutations.
- Ooh, that's a relief.
- Important, important,
important, important,
commercial genetic tests do not test
for all the types of variants
for a lot of these conditions.
So, I don't want people
to do these tests thinking
that they're all good.
And remember,
not all cancers are genetic.
Many of them develop spontaneously,
some as a result of lifestyle habits
like binging alcohol or
overeating fried or fatty foods.
- So, if I'm not predisposed
to having cholesterol issues
I don't have to worry
about eating a ton of fried
chicken like I already-
- You do, though!
See, that's what we wanna avoid!
- So, I'm great?
- Yeah.
- My genes could not be better.
- That's right.
- Wow, so I get candy?
- "My genes can not be better,"
she goes, "That's right."
"It's what you paid us for."
- So, that doesn't guarantee
that you won't get cancer in the future
or that you don't have an increased risk
based on other genes or
other non-genetic factors.
- There's the legal stuff!
Or how about saying the fact
that you may still have cancer right now,
that would've killed
the vibe of the video.
- We did find one mutation
in a gene called B-R-C-A 1.
Or some people call it BRCA1.
- BRCA, yeah, I know about BRCA.
- Is that something that's been tested for
in your family, or how
did you know about it?
- So, my mother had breast cancer
and it was discovered that
she had the BRCA1 gene.
I know that, it's very
common in Ashkenazi Jews.
And that, if you have
it, there's a 50% chance
of you passing it down to your children.
I put off getting the test
'cause I'm like, "I don't wanna know."
- Also, if you have a BRCA1 gene mutation,
there has been a correlation
with more aggressive prostate cancer,
if you do develop prostate cancer.
BRCA2 has been more correlated
with actually development
of prostate cancer.
- I know that it affects
women a lot more seriously
than men, and luckily my
sister and the other women
in my family all tested negative
for it, which is relieving.
So, I have it.
So, what does that mean?
- Having that gene
increases your likelihood
of getting breast cancer, not a guarantee.
- Something like knowing
that I have the BRCA
gene, can be really scary.
But instead, I'm gonna
look at the positive.
You know, knowledge is power.
- There's a lot you can do to prevent it.
Reducing your risk of cancer,
oftentimes, it's reducing
your alcohol intake,
eating healthy, fresh
foods is really important.
And then exercise, is really, really key
in cancer reductions.
- Isn't it interesting how the advice
for whether you're talking
about reducing prostate cancer,
losing weight, decreasing
cardiac risk is all the same?
Exercise, eat lots of
fruits and vegetables,
and meats in moderation,
sleep well, mindfulness,
it doesn't matter, plug in
whatever disease you want,
that's the advice.
So, why bother going to
get screened for that?
- Exercising just 30 minutes
a day, five days a week.
- What about an hour, three times a week?
- Whatever works for you,
as long as you're able
to put in those two and a half
hours of exercise per week.
- It has to be moderate
intensity exercise.
If you know, you know.
Is this moderate intensity exercise?
(Zach mumbling)
So, the fact that the blood
pressure is being checked
while he's talking, is actually wrong.
You have to be seated
for at least 10 minutes,
feet touching the ground.
Their feet are dangling.
You have to be in a comfortable position
not have recently smoked, not
have recently drank caffeine
not be talking, have your
arms completely at rest.
And ideally, you wanna do
it on an automated cuff
and leave the room,
so that the cuff can get the measurement
without a person in the room.
Because otherwise,
you're gonna get falsely
elevated readings.
- Your blood pressure's
really nice and low.
It's 112 over 70.
What does your heart rate
usually run, do you know?
- I have no idea.
- Okay, well you're at 87.
- Is that good?
- It's normal.
We know that we can get
your heart rate lower
when people do vigorous exercise.
The best way to lower one's heart rate,
and it's actually the training
that I'm going through right now
for boxing, is through high
intensity interval training.
I've heard the people
that I work with, call
it almost body building
for the heart.
As a doctor, I don't
quite like that statement
because an enlarged heart
is actually a bad heart.
But, you want a stronger heart,
in that, it doesn't need to pump as often,
which allows it to calm down, relax,
better improve filling time, all of that.
And, we've seen better survival rates
through heart attacks, less heart attacks
when you have a lower resting heart rate.
Usually, that comes from exercise.
You could also, have a
low resting heart rate,
very low, that is
pathologic, meaning it's not
because you exercise well and
you actually have a problem.
That's why we have the
term bradycardia for it,
because Tom Brady's really slow.
- [Commentator] And Brady, very upset.
- [Doctor] People who sleep less
than seven hours a night,
actually have a shorter
life expectancy, and so-
- Wait less than what?
- [Doctor] Seven hours.
- But, they're also awake more,
they're living life,
more than the sleepers.
- [Doctor] But, Keith.
- I'm pretty sure that's not the case,
because when we look
at scientific evidence
and we look at, we used to do years lost,
so if X number of people died,
and we know that they're age 40,
we say that their average
life expectancy is 77.
So, we do 27 years of
life lost per person,
and 1,000 people died,
we'd say 27,000 years lost.
In this case, if you die
10 years prematurely,
how many hours is that,
10 years times 365 times 24?
I can't do that math,
but it's a huge number.
I can't imagine you're
saving that much more
by getting one hour extra
activity and not sleeping.
- [Doctor] When people
aren't sleeping, it starts
to affect their heart health.
You might feel invincible
now, and it changes on a dime.
- And not only does it affect your heart,
it also affects your brain.
I feel like as we come to terms
with the sleep deprivation
that we currently face in our society,
we'll come to terms with the idea
that Alzheimer's, and all of
these neurological disorders
that are on the rise can
be potentially fueled
by the lack of sleep that
our society's getting.
- Often, we think about aging
with physical health only.
How much does mental
health actually affect,
how long you'll live?
- It's huge, yeah.
It can end up increasing
our risk of heart disease.
It increases our risk
of things like diabetes.
- I have a newborn baby.
So, sometimes it's hard
to find time for myself.
- When we're talking about
someone not sleeping enough,
and we're talking about
chronic sleep deprivation,
we're really talking about a lifestyle.
If your baby for the first two,
three weeks is not sleeping great
and causing you to wake up up early,
that's not gonna have a drastic impact
on your entire lifespan.
But, if that becomes your
normal habit that even
when your child is one, two, three,
four, five, six years of age,
that's when it becomes a problem.
It's a chronic issue.
- There is a healthy level
of stress that you can have
where it's like,
"I'm a little stressed about this test.
It helps me perform."
- If you make stress your friend,
if you view it in a positive light
like the doctor just said,
that you view it as a preparation
for a challenge and something
that just comes with life
that you have to manage,
versus all stress is bad,
you actually get better outcomes
even when you have more stress.
- [Doctor] Let's talk about sexual health.
- Sure, what do you wanna know?
- Yeah.
- [Doctor] If you have a preference
for male or female partner-
- Wasn't this supposed
to be about how long they're gonna live?
- [Sam] Mm-hmm.
- Is this still the same video?
- [Doctor] Or both, the number
of sexual partners you've had
in the past week or the past month,
I also ask my patients what
body parts they have sex with.
The anus, is it the
penis, is it your mouth?
Which body parts do you use for sex?
- Hmm, go ahead Zach.
(men laughing)
Go ahead Zach.
- A lot of people don't
feel comfortable talking
to their PCPs about their sexual-
- Especially, in a group of
their friends around them.
So, I understand that.
- I'm comfortable with it,
but the person who I'm seeing-
- [Doctor] Oh, yeah.
- Probably less comfortable with it.
- Yeah, and also, when I
have younger patients, teens
and such, and their
parents are in the room,
I actually ask the parent to step out
when I have that conversation.
- Is there anything that
you're worried about
or anything that you
anticipate with your labs?
- No, but also everything.
- The one I'm always terrified
of, is the STD testing.
- What if we have one of 'em?
- We can treat you!
- We'll make a very interesting video.
- Even though I have no reason to believe
that I'm positive for any.
- I know for the video,
they're probably gonna
order a broad set of labs,
but I want you to know at home
that, not everything needs
to be checked on your labs.
I have many patients
that come in that say,
"Doctor I wanna be checked,
I wanna make sure I don't have
this, I don't have cancer,
I don't have that."
It's impossible, I can never
give you 100% assurance
that you're not gonna have a heart attack
when you walk outside my office,
that you're not gonna develop
a cancer the next day.
There exists, no such test.
Conditions that you already have,
your age, your risk factors,
those are the things
that need to be taken into consideration
when deciding what blood test to order.
- Lay it on me, what's
the good or bad news?
- Your blood sugar
level, we want that level
to be under 100,
and yours was 81, which is great.
And yours was 77.
Yours was 117.
- Okay.
- Which is totally
normal for having eaten.
- Okay, I was a about
to say, "I wonder if these are fasting."
Ideally, we want the
number to be under 100.
If it's between 100 and 125,
that's the pre-diabetic range.
Over 125, that is the diabetic range, now.
Once you have diabetes,
technically, there is no cure.
Pre-diabetes, you can reverse.
So, we encourage those
people to work really hard
to reduce that.
- Let's get to the STI testing,
the sexually transmitted
infection testing.
And, you don't have chlamydia,
gonorrhea, HIV or syphilis.
So, those all came back negative.
- That's great news.
Which one of us do you
think will live the longest?
- Here's why I can't know that, is
because I don't know when you
guys walk out of this door,
what lifestyle changes you're gonna make.
- Or, because you're not
a psychic, unanswerable.
- Let's say we make no changes.
- Based on a lot of sleeping habits,
and eating habits, and exercising,
and mental health and wellness,
I'm going to have to point to Ned.
(Ned gasps)
- Which one of the three of us needs
to make the life changes the most?
- Well, I would say all
three of you, actually.
- So, we're all gonna die.
- [Doctor] Being totally honest.
- We'll die together!
- Oh my God!
- Wow, that would be so cute.
- Did you know
that I turned down a
multi-million dollar TV deal?
Click here for that story,
it's very interesting, tells you all
about how the media process works,
and how truly, truly evil,
and corrupt the business is.
Click here to check that out.
As always, stay happy and healthy.